what are the rules about dating
Intelligence Officers within the agency
it's actually much more common than
people think we often joke that the CIA
is the best dating service in the world
so you basically have to lie to
everybody else but be honest with the
people inside the building all those
hookups that you keep around just in
case when you go into the agency you
have to cut off ties to all of those
people because every one of them is a
security concern for you so you just
start fresh you end up meeting these
people inside the agency they're all
very smart interesting they've all got
great backgrounds so you end up having
these very genuine relationships inside
we can work on the same case and have
dinner in the cafeteria together and
then we can go home and we can do
whatever we want to do at home too and
all we have to do is not talk about work
at home so there's actually a great deal
of intramural dating large number of
people who end up getting married to
other agency officers because your whole
life becomes the world of intelligence
you don't want to go out and have a
happy hour with strangers because
strangers are at risk stay in the
building and have happy hour with
friends in the building so there's quite
a bit of that that happens internally